what do you think of uh Max tag Mark who
wrote the book mathematical universe
so do you think just lingering on that
point you think at the end of the day
the future Generations will all be
mathematicians
meaning meaning the ones that deeply
understand the way the universe works at
the core is it just
mathematics
at the core of you know
I would say mathematics is one half of
the core so the book is called love and
math yeah okay so these are the two
pillars yeah
in my view yes in other words you can't
cover everything by math so mathematics
gives you tools it gives you way up uh
kind of a clear
vision
but Mad Max by itself is not enough for
one to have a harmonious and and
balanced life you know so I I am
suspicious of any theory that
declares that everything is mathematics
so math can generate things that are
beautiful but it can't explain why it's
beautiful Matthew could say is a way to
discern patterns to find regularities in
the universe and both physical and
mental Universe the mathematics explores
the mind as much as it explores
um the physical world around us and it
helps us to find those patterns
um which kind of which makes our
perception more sophisticated our
ability to perceive things such as
Beauty
you know and
it sharpens our ability to see to see
beauty to understand Beauty so a world
becomes more complex from thinking that
our
that our that Earth is flat we go to
realizing that it is round that is
shaped as a sphere
so that we can actually travel around
the Earth you know so there isn't a
place where we hit the end so to speak
and then
[Music]
um
proceeding in the same vein then
Einstein's general relativity Theory
tells us that
our space-time is not flat either
this is much harder to to imagine the
band a band three-dimensional or
four-dimensional three-dimensional space
or four-dimensional space time because
this idea that the space around us is
flat is so deeply entrenched and yet we
know from this from this Theory
and from the experiments that have
confirmed it
that
a array of light bends around a star as
if being attracted by the by the force
of gravity but in fact the force of
gravity is the bending it's just that
it's not only depending on the space
it's also the bending of space-time
there is a curvature not only between
special spatial dimensions
the way parallels and meridians come
together in a small scale they look like
perpendicular lines but if you zoom out
you see that the spacer at a curving the
space they are sort of the the tracks
along which the space gets curved that's
that's the that would be the curvature
of spatial Dimensions but in fact now
throw in time and one time the imagine a
sphere which lives which has one of the
meridians correspond to time and the
parallel is crisp into space I can't
imagine it but you can I can write
mathematical formula expressing that
curvature and that's in fact that
curvature is responsible for the force
of gravity attraction between the sort
of simplest instantiation of it
attraction between two planets
all between two human beings
yeah the time
bending time
it's not very nice that what that theory
did to time because
it feels like the marching of time
forward is fundamental to our Human
Experience
the era of time
marching forward nicely seems to be the
only way we can understand the universe
and the fact that you can start now up
to now there are people who claim that
they can that they have they possess
other ways of of experiencing it so
truly can visualize messing with time
well messing with time but not
necessarily messing with time because
one point of view is that you know
I think who who was it I think William
Blake
who wrote that
eternity loves time production
so
one point of view is that it is eternity
which is fundamental where time stands
still which our mind conceptualizes as
the time
so but in fact you know it's not
something mystical if you think about
when you about it
when you really absorbed in something
time does the stand still and then you
look at the clock and it's like oh my
God two hours have passed and it felt
like a couple of seconds
when you are absorbed when you're in
love when you are a passionate about
something when you're creating something
you're we lose ourselves and we lose the
sense of time and space for that matter
you see so there is only that which is
happening that creative process
um so I think that this this is familiar
to all of us and we may be actually the
closest to the truth at that moment to
the truth so yes so then there is a
point of view that this is where we are
We Are Who We Are at our sort of
fundamental at our fundamental level and
after that the Mind comes in
and tries to conceptualize it it's like
oh because I was writing something
um
I was writing a book I was painting this
painting or maybe I was watching this
painting and got totally absorbed in it
or I fell in love with this person
that's what happened but in the moment
when it's happening you're not thinking
about it
he was just there yeah we construct
narratives around the set of memories
that that seem to have happened in
sequence or at least that's the way we
tell ourselves that and we also have a
bunch of weird human things like
Consciousness and the experience of free
will that we chose a set of actions as
the time unrolled forward right and we
are intelligent conscious agents making
tastes taking those actions
but what if all of that is just an
illusion an illusion and a nice
narrative would tell ourselves sure
that's a really difficult thing possible
and imagine imagine that to make it
really Catch-22 that our imagine that
our minds and are set up in such a way
yeah
that they can't approach the world or
experience otherwise
so in other words to understand to see
that from a more
um kind of all-encompassing point of
view we have to step out of the Mind
well I wonder what's the more honest way
to look at things
but I think we like to be to play with
time I think we like to play with these
experiences with all the drama of it
with all the memories with all the
tribulations yeah I think we love it we
love it otherwise we wouldn't be doing
it I think this or Earth loves it The
evolutionary process somehow loves it
whatever whatever this thing that's
being created here on Earth it seems to
like to create like to allow its
children to play with certain
uh yeah truths that they hold this
subjective truths that are useful for
the competition or whatever this dance
that we call Life broadly defined not
just humans